welcome to sas talks money on
valuetainment economics i'm your host
adam sosnick and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and save
that money on today's episode it's all
about where you
should live let's talk money
[Music]
so let me ask you a question do you
prefer to rent
or do you prefer to buy i want to get
your opinion
no like literally i want to get your
opinion please comment below and let me
know
how you feel we value your comments we
read all your comments comments like
this
and also comments like this and even not
so nice comments
like this it's all good we're big boys
we're big girls around here we
appreciate your feedback
we love your comments we are here for
you so with that being said
we're here for you we want to know all
about you what do you prefer
renting or buying that's the question so
let me ask you if you
google rent versus buy do you know what
pops up literally a million different
articles
saying completely different things half
the articles say
no way should you rent it's throwing
away money you're paying your landlord's
mortgage
you're pissing money away and then the
other half articles are saying
home ownership is overrated it's not
worth it it's a complete waste of time
it's a scam
so which one is it let's get into the
numbers so today mortgage rates are some
of the lowest of all time they're
hovering around three percent to put
that in perspective
in the 90s mortgage rates were 10
and in the 80s mortgage rates were
around 18
what mind-blown brains all over the
walls right now that's crazy
so to put it in perspective three
percent very low all-time lows
now the average home value in america
today is somewhere between
a quarter million dollars and 300 000
depending on where you live speaking of
where you live it's all about location
location location location
let's get into some of the most
expensive and least expensive places
that you can live so the least expensive
place the cheapest place that you can
live is in west virginia
sorry mountaineers you can buy a place
in west virginia for a hundred and eight
thousand dollars why aren't why you're
pretty cheap there i don't know if you
want to live in west virginia though
however the most expensive state to live
in is the beautiful islands of hawaii
to buy a house there at 635 thousand
dollars that ain't cheap baby
now let's get into the most expensive
cities to rent this is for a one bedroom
can you guess what number one is number
one san francisco
number two new york city number three
san jose just outside of san francisco
so it's a little
push over from there number four boston
number five
la number six oakland just close to san
francisco so anywhere near san francisco
costs an arm and a leg to live number
seven our country's capital washington
dc it is not cheap there
number eight seattle up on that west
coast and number nine
san diego weather weather weather and
number ten my hometown of miami so
that's the top ten most expensive
cities to live in america now what's the
least expensive cities to live these are
cities where
not that many people are trying to live
at so that's why it's so cheap
let's break that down the cheapest place
to live can you guess it
can you guess it it's toledo ohio it
only costs a little over 500
for a one bedroom there not too many
people i guess are trying to live in
toledo
number two on that list evansville
indiana number three
green bay wisconsin go packers number
four rochester new york
number five columbia maryland six tucson
arizona seven fargo eight
springfield missouri number nine lubbock
texas
and number 10 bakersfield california so
that is the most expensive cities to
rent
and the least expensive cities to rent
as a cross reference here we go moving
on
where can you get the best bang for your
buck if you're going to buy
if you want to buy you want to get a
good bang for your buck right this whole
show is all about saving money so i'd be
remiss if i didn't put this on the list
what's the best bang for your buck well
it's motor city baby detroit number one
city best bang for your buck
here we go number two cleveland number
three
memphis four toledo five buffalo
six pittsburgh number seven corpus
christi texas
eight milwaukee wisconsin number nine
baltimore and number 10
lubbock again so that's some of the you
know now we're going back and forth here
least expensive most expensive so now we
got a little sort of lay of the land
here what's going on what's cheap what's
expensive where should you live
what's what's cost a pretty penny what
what's a bang for your buck
now what are the experts say so here are
a couple expert opinions for you number
one first expert i'd like you to check
out this article
from our founder patrick that david this
guy's a multi-millionaire
yet for the longest time he rented why
did this guy rent he could live anywhere
he wanted but he decided to rent hmm
what's up with that
i don't care about buying a house the
american dream to me
is not buying a house the american dream
to me is freedom
that's what the american dream to me is
number two i interviewed samantha
dibiancy she was on million dollar
listing miami she's a realtor you see
her on fox business she's all over the
news
she's obviously a huge advocate of
buying so that's someone else
when can i debate these experts that say
that owning a home is not a good
investment
and number three you got this guy grant
cardone he runs cardone capital he's a
huge real estate investor
however all he does is rent his
apartment and you don't own a house a
personal house
yeah well you know i rent i rent my
house
right i get a better loan on it because
i rent it hmm what's going on here rent
buy buy rent many different examples
here from experts
so that got me thinking does it make
sense to rent or does it make sense to
buy
now with that being said let's take it
to the tape now it's time for the tail
of the tape
within the tail of the tape we compare
and contrast
two different options that you can
choose from in this case it's renting
versus buying what do you think please
leave a comment i'd love
to get your feedback we're going to be
checking comments and responding back to
you
and if you like what we're doing here on
valuetainment economics go ahead and
smash that like button and don't forget
to subscribe
all right here we go let's get into the
tale of the tape
so in america today you got 35 percent
of people prefer to rent and 65
of people are homeowners so what does
that mean exactly
one-third of people rent and two-thirds
of people are homeowners
now if you're gonna rent that's gonna
cost you on average a little over a
thousand bucks a month
that's all in for for a renter now if
you're gonna be a homeowner on average
that's gonna cost you a little over
fifteen hundred dollars a month that's a
fifty percent difference
so let's understand what that difference
actually entails okay
so you're looking for a new place to
live you're deciding whether you want to
rent you're deciding whether you want to
buy now let's talk about
the upfront cost what's it going to cost
you to get in the door now if you're
going to rent
let's break that down rent when you go
to a building you got to usually start
with an application fee that costs you
basically a hundred bucks you fill out
an application they do a background
check
they'll see i don't know what this
person can move in they should they not
doesn't cost you a lot of money however
if you're going to go and try to buy a
place and you talk about upfront costs
you talk about transaction fees
now if you're going to buy a place
that's a different story let's break
that down
so usually upfront costs include all
this hope you're taking notes
transaction costs include inspections
appraisal loan origination fees
government agency fees
titles escrow and then you get this
closing costs might be two to five
percent of your purchase price
and then if you're buying a place
there's a sales commission which ranges
from three to six percent
now let's talk about a down payment if
you're going to rent a place usually
sometimes you got to put down first
last and security that's like worst case
scenario there are other places where
they say all right look just start
paying rent put down a little security
deposit you're moving right in
now if you're going to be putting down a
down payment for a new place to live
the average down payment in america
today is around 12
so let's break down what that numbers
mean twelve percent is the average
first-time buyers you can get it as low
as six percent there's also something
called the
fha loan which is low is 3.5 percent
but they recommend here we go here now
they recommend you put down
20 as a down payment so you can avoid
paying
pmi which is private mortgage insurance
so that's a little lay of the land when
it comes to upfront costs
and down payments so now let's get into
the big one which is debt which is
mortgage
versus no mortgage which you're paying
interest rates or you're paying no
interest rates
well when you're renting there's no debt
there's no interest rates there's no
financing
so you just pay what you pay for rent
now when it comes to buying you usually
have to get
a mortgage unless you're buying a place
just straight cash i don't know if
you're doing that
so a mortgage today as we discussed
they're hovering at some of the lowest
rates ever closer to three percent
now do you qualify for that how's your
credit these are some of the things that
you need to consider
when you're looking for a mortgage now
when it comes to a mortgage there's some
good news and there's some bad news
right
so some of the good is your mortgage
interest payments you could write off
it's a tax deduction
now some of the bad news is this whether
you're getting a 15-year mortgage
or a 30-year mortgage check this the
first
two thirds of what you're paying so
that's 20 years on the 30 year
or 10 years on a 15 year the first two
thirds
you're only paying interest right you're
paying the bank
for two thirds of the time the other
last third
is when you can start knocking out
principle that's that blew my mind i did
not know that when it came to buying a
place
so understand that there's good and bad
with taking out a mortgage you can write
off the interest
but also it's going to take you a while
to hit that principle
so when it comes to renting versus
buying there's three
major factors the big three if you will
and here's what they are
maintenance taxes and insurance
let's break down those three major
factors here we go now if you rent
this is what i call the beauty of
renting you don't have to pay anything
for the most part for any of those three
major factors so if you rent you have
zero maintenance costs that you need to
pay that is not on you that is on
the landlord how beautiful is that
that's what i call the beauty of renting
so no maintenance no out of pocket for
you
so if you're the type of person that
can't even change a light bulb
maybe you should consider renting all
right number two property taxes if you
rent
no property taxes done that's it you're
moving on number three when it comes to
insurance
maybe you have to get renters insurance
which can be as low as five
ten dollars a month for a renter's
insurance so when it comes to these
three major factors as being a renter
these are three major factors to
consider you got no maintenance
you got no taxes and very limited
insurance that you would need
now on the flip side here are the big
three factors when it comes
to buying right let's jump into it so
number one when it comes to maintenance
upkeep and hoa which stands for the home
owners association you gotta understand
something boom boom boom and bold
letters it's on
you if maintenance is on you what does
that entail for you well that means this
you're responsible for the gardening
you're responsible for the pool
you're responsible for the roof you're
responsible if the ac goes out you're
responsible if there's a toilet issue
you're responsible if there's leaky
pipes etc etc etc
here's my advice for you if you're a
homeowner expect
the unexpected so understand that you
might need to come out of pocket with
500 bucks
1000 bucks 5 000 bucks to fix these
expenses and what i hope you have
are some cash reserves so you don't have
to put this on a credit card
and not so good okay now if you're the
type of person who's like a missed or
fix it that can fix all these things
that you don't have to
contract somebody to come in and fix it
then maybe being a homeowner
is right for you number two when it
comes to property taxes this also ranges
between one
and four percent of your home value now
property taxes depends on what we always
talk about location location location
right so in certain locations it's
closer to one percent and in other
locations it's closer to four percent
so understand what you're getting
yourself into when you're becoming a
homeowner when it comes to property tax
what are these property taxes for well
to pay for schools
streets police fire department many
different services
that your tax dollars are there for all
right number three
insurance unlike renters insurance which
is five ten twenty bucks a month nothing
big
homeowners insurance on average is one
percent of your home value
so if your home is three hundred
thousand dollars one percent of that is
three thousand dollars that's what
you're paying
in homeowners insurance now what does
that cover that covers things like
flood insurance earthquake insurance
hurricane insurance
fire insurance god forbid anything's
happened your home
is protected so that's what i call the
big three
factors that you need to consider
whether you're going to rent or whether
you're going to buy
so that leads us to our next category
which is predictability meaning
what can you expect to pay now when
you're a renter you can expect to pay
the
absolute max a month meaning you know
your maximum meaning
you know that every month the maximum
amount that you'll be paying
is rent and utilities that's it that's
your max that's what you're paying
moving on so when you're a homeowner
you're only going to know the minimum
that you'll ever pay you're never really
going to know the maximum why is that
because we know
that you're going to be paying your
mortgage and utilities and besides that
you've got maintenance you've got upkeep
you've got taxes you've got insurance
but beyond that you never really know
what's going to happen right
so you're only going to know the minimum
that you'll be paying moving right along
here's my favorite part of being a
renter it's all about the flexibility
meaning
no long-term commitment meaning you can
move year to year depending on your life
situation let's get into it you can make
moves easily all of a sudden your income
goes up let's move to a nicer place
all of a sudden your income goes down oh
not so sure we might have to move
you're making moves and you're making
moves easily that's flexibility when it
comes
to renting now if you're a homeowner
your flexibility
not so much it's actually the exact
opposite of being flexible it has very
low flexibility if you're a homeowner
you're probably staying put for a while
why is that
because it's an illiquid hard asset
there's nothing wrong with that
but you'll be probably staying put for a
little while now if you wanted to sell
your house and you said i got to get out
of this
just understand that on average it takes
you 60 to 90 days to sell your house
from the time that it's listed so now
it's on to customization now this is a
major
pro if you're going to buy customization
meaning you can do what you want to do
with your house you can see it's here in
purple you do what you want to do if you
want to paint the walls purple
you go ahead and you paint them purple
you want to have pets you want to have
parties it's your
property you do what you want now if
you're a renter
not so much you can't do what you want
to do why because it's the landlord's
discretion
now if your landlord's cool hey maybe he
lets you do
kind of things you want to do but if
your landlord's an [ __ ] you got to
play by his or her rule so
understand that customization favors
being a homeowner
versus being a renter that's on you
though now let's talk
opportunity cost that's what it's all
about how much money
is this costing you now if you're a
homeowner you got to understand
something
a lot of your money is being pumped into
your house which isn't necessarily a bad
thing
but here's what it is it's almost like a
forced savings plan
meaning every single month every single
year of your life
boom payment boom payment boom payment
you're building up
equity in your home you're hopefully
getting appreciation
within your home on average homes
appreciate
year over year three percent so it's
almost like a forced
savings plan like i said increasing the
value of your home
so that is a homeowner that is the
opportunity cost of being a homeowner so
now if you're a renter i want you to
listen and i want you to listen good
you have to and i mean have to invest
elsewhere
if you're just renting and just paying
rent and doing nothing else with your
money
i'd rather you buy straight up however
if you're gonna rent you have to be
investing in other asset classes now
what are these other asset classes
that we're talking about so for me
example i rent and i
invest all my money in the stock market
and a little bit in my business so
that's what's worked for me
so my advice for you if you're going to
be a renter that's cool
right we just went down the list of some
of the advantages of renting
but if you're not investing elsewhere
you're missing the boat
where else can you invest like i said in
the stock market you can invest in
business
you can even invest in reits which is
real estate investment trust
you can invest in real estate without
investing in literally being a homeowner
so with these investment opportunities
you can make
6 10 12 20 on your money
versus maybe three percent being a
homeowner so understand what i'm saying
here
if you're gonna be a renter that's cool
but you have to invest
so moving right along let's talk about
equity now if you're a renter
you know how much equity you build in
your place nothing nothing you're not
building
any equity however you're not losing any
of your equity so you know you're not
building but not losing
now if you're a home owner you're
hopefully
building equity it's not guaranteed
you're not always going to make money
but more often than not you will be
building equity
in your home now what are some of the
advantages of building
equity in your home let's break that
down now if you build
equity that means you have a higher
value of your house which is basically a
safety net
so meaning yo if i need some money if i
need to pull out some money
i can refinance my mortgage i can do a
heloc which is a home equity line of
credit
i can tap into the value of my home so
understand the difference between no
equity
and equity so what does this mean for
you in the long run now
understand if you're a renter you're
going to be making
payments for life that's year after year
after year you're building no equity
you don't own the place there's no
finish line in sight every year of your
life you got to be paying rent
so i mean how do you feel about that how
do you feel about knowing that if you're
a renter you're paying rent straight up
every year of your life all right i'm
not saying there's anything wrong with
that
just understand that now if you're a
homeowner here's the beautiful part
about being a homeowner
you're playing the long game and there's
a finish line
in sight it might take you 15 years it
might take you 30 years but at some
point
you'll have that home paid off but just
keep in mind like we talked about
the big three over here when you do pay
off your home you still need to be
paying
taxes insurance and maintenance those
things aren't going away so
understand the long game so now let's
talk about worst
case scenario these are things that
nobody really wants to talk about who
wants to talk about worst case scenario
but we'll talk about it
if you're a homeowner and you fail to
pay your mortgage now what happens to
you
you get foreclosed on this happened to a
lot of people a lot of people
2009 we'll see what happens in 2020 but
a lot of people in 2020
are making sure they're making their
payments because they can't leave their
house
now if you're a renter and you don't pay
your rent what happens well you got to
go buddy you just got evicted
so these are some of the worst case
scenarios between being a homeowner
and a renter now what does it all come
down to i think we can understand here
it is by far cheaper to rent
right but you're going to be making
payments the rest of your life so it's
cheaper
but every single year you're gonna be
making payments so being a homeowner is
definitely more expensive we went down
the line here of why it's more expensive
but here's a little not so fun fact for
you to just keep in the back of your
mind did you know
that over 30 years of paying off your
mortgage you'll actually end up paying
double what you bought your house for
let me say that again
if you bought your house for 250 000
over 30 years you'll end up making
almost
500 000 in payment i don't know how you
feel about that did you know that
so that's the difference between being a
renter and a homeowner
so the question is this who do you
want to be what kind of lifestyle do you
want to lead
i want to know please let us know in the
comments what kind of lifestyle
you're more interested in now let's
break this down who should rent
and who should buy so you should rent if
you are more interested in mobility
flexibility freedom of movement you're
unsure of your next move it's okay to be
unsure of what your next moves are but
if you're unsure
it's probably better to be a renter so
you're not locked in if you're changing
your mind a lot you're not sure i don't
know
should i stay in this career should i
change careers should i live here should
i not live here
probably better to be a renter renting
just so you know is more about a short
term
right short term i'm not sure here where
am i going what am i doing
all about the short term now also one of
the
benefits of renting is you can have
roommates you and a buddy or two or a
girlfriend of yours boom hey let's just
put the rent here
rent two thousand thousand thousand no
big deal we're splitting the rent it's
all good having roommates
and here's the last thing when it comes
to renting if you already have
high debt in your life meaning you got
student loans
you got a credit card loans you got auto
loans the last thing you need to be
doing is adding another
quarter million dollars of debt into
your life so understand that's who
should be renting
so now who should buy you should buy if
you're a little more stable secure
you're stationary you ain't going
anywhere for a little while
you're going to be raising a family you
know exactly where you want to be
this is what we call the american dream
pride of home ownership
settling down having a family you're
planning your route sense of community
these are the perks of being a homeowner
now if you're a homeowner don't plan on
moving for at least five to ten years
that's kind of the whole point of all
this
you're staying put so the last thing
i'll say is if you have low debt and you
have trouble saving this might be a
great savings plan
for you right we talked about a forced
savings plan so those are some of the
benefits of being a home
owner okay so now it's time for did you
know
did you know that between the ages of 18
and 48 that's 30 years right there
between the ages of 18 and 48
the average american will have 12 jobs
in that time period that averages out to
one job
every two and a half years so what does
that mean between those ages of 20 and
30 essentially in that age bracket
you got to stay flexible you might be
moving jobs especially
these days now let's talk about regret
according to cnbc
44 of homeowners regretted
purchasing a home and even more
mind-blowing 63 percent of millennials
regretted buying a home so what's my
point my point is this
you got to know what you're getting
yourself into before you become a
homeowner
so now if you're unsure of whether you
still want to rent or buy we've actually
attached
a link down below to give you a
cost-benefit analysis of becoming a
renter
versus a buyer so the links below and
now it's time for the bottom line and
what's the bottom line
no longer is it a one-size-fits-all
cookie cutter approach
to choosing whether you should live you
know what you should do
you should do you do what you want to do
do what fits
your lifestyle you no longer have to
live your life based on old mantras now
what do i mean
if you want to be a homeowner that's
cool own your home just don't let your
home
own you now if you want to be a renter
that's cool too but you have to
have to invest in other asset classes
whether that's a stock market
whether that's in reits whether that's
in your business you have to invest
now speaking of investing if you have
not seen my video on how to win the
money game
check that out right here and if you
have not seen my video on 10 things that
are absolutely killing your wealth
check that out right here and right
below please consider subscribing to
valuetainment economics
we would appreciate it and last but not
least whether you're going to rent
or whether you're going to buy you need
to do the math
and save that all we talk is money
all we talk is money all we talk is